ray is with us ray is uh in louisville
kentucky hi ray how are you
hello dave it's a real pleasure to speak
to you you too how can we help
well in late 2019 my income
roughly tripled a good problem to have
and in 2020 i got real aggressive with
paying off debt
i was able to clear off a motorcycle
debt
all credit cards and the last two items
are now a house
and a car but one of the things i also
did over 2020 is i bought bitcoin
and it's ballooned into this huge
account now
worth roughly a hundred thousand dollars
so one of the things i want to do with
it is obviously pay off the car but it's
not quite enough
to pay off the house so i guess my
question is
do i wait with this volatile asset or do
i sell it all and move it into something
more traditional
because over the course of 2020 i
actually did the figures and it's earned
me
649 percent and the expectations are
uh that it could go even higher now it's
a volatile asset
it swings now every day
you know it was worth the swings now are
more than it was worth a year ago
um so i guess i'm just kind of nervous
about keeping this large
amount of cash in this volatile asset
and but still having to worry about
a house that i'd like to pay off in the
meantime
yeah you're you got vegas problems man
i mean you walked up to the slot machine
put a quarter in and it dumped a bunch
of quarters out and now you want to
you have this temptation to think that's
a plan yeah um
and so and thus is the problem with
anything that is a
extremely uh volatile
uh asset to use your phrase and also
uh un you know unpredictable which is
the volatility so um
you're asking me what i would do i would
cash it all out tomorrow
i wouldn't have been in it in the first
place though so
well i was you know i'm single i felt
like i could afford to take the risk
i had a snowball plan for all the other
items
yeah and the next two you know the next
two that's what the guy told me when he
was playing the roulette wheel too
yeah yeah yeah so i mean you know i i i
can afford to lose the money and i call
this entertainment
um and he lost you know i stood there
and watched him lose 10 grand and
at the blackjack table so um you know
you can do whatever you want to do
but you're asking me what i would do uh
i wouldn't have been in the first place
and i wouldn't stay in it and i would
cash it out tomorrow
and i would put the money on some common
sense things
yes instead of playing instead you know
you're sitting here
explaining to me all the problems with
the
investment yeah yeah and you know you
already know what you need to do yeah
you just want somebody else to say it
out loud and he's trying to justify with
his age like i'm young
i have time to lose money i don't care
man i'm young i do not have
time to lose money to lose money does
that mean i can get over my stupid later
right
you know i'm in debt i have a car that i
probably
well i want to say that you probably
couldn't afford the car but you couldn't
afford the car
could you finance it but anyways what
i'm saying now is
i agree with dave be young be wise
cash it out pay off the car and
take your fabulous income and use that
to build wealth with that is a much more
proven strategy to build wealth
than playing volatile assets yeah you
know you
buying gold or buying commodities or
buying bitcoin or
buying currencies uh i mean there's a
lot of volatile
you can do options i mean you could be
you can be playing
you know you can be selling short on the
market you can be day trading there's
all kinds of things you can
do right and occasionally make money at
it and most of the time end up losing it
all right
and uh bitcoin is in that category i
mean it's a
a high risk play and i don't know if the
numbers have changed dave but it was
isn't it right around nearly 80 percent
of people lose money
on day trading on day trade yeah bitcoin
but you know yeah
the bitcoins had a fabulous run yeah in
the last year but that doesn't mean it's
a
an investment you need to do right i
mean gold had a fabulous run for
for a while there but that means
investment you need to do right
uh these commodity plays or and currency
plays are just dangerous
yeah and so you do what you want to do
right but i i have zero money invested
in that type of thing
i work too hard for it and i really
don't have any desire to lose it
um the government takes enough of it
without me losing it
and and you know that that it's up
but again you you know you're looking at
the rate of return
and you're measuring that against your
risk and you're going to make that call
and but you asked us what we would do
and that's what you'll get here is we're
an
expert on our opinion